شكرا لك طاهر بالفعل مشاهدينا المستمرون
معكم في التغطيه طبعا الابرز كما تابعتم
قبل قليل حديث جون كربي المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي في البيت الابيض
تحدث للزميل طاهر مباشره من البيت الابيض
وطبعا اهم ما قاله جون كربي قبل قليل
للعربيه بان الولايات المتحده لا تتدخل في
الحرب في السودان بل تسعى لتسويه
النزاع ووقف القتال قال جون كربي للعربيه
في هذا الحوار المباشر قبل قليل كذلك اكد
جونكر طبعا بان هناك جهودا مستمره لتمديد
الهدنه في السودان اشهد كذلك بدور
السعوديه التي ساعدت باجلاء عددين كبير من
الرعايه من السودان يقول جون كيربي كذلك
في حديثه العربيه اكد المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي بانه على طرفي النزاع في
السودان وقف القتال وادخال المساعدات وقال
ان الولايات المتحده تركز حاليا على وقف
القتال في السودان ومغادره الرعايه
الاجانب وبان الولايات المتحده ترحب بكل
المبادرات بما في ذلك مبادره منظمه
الايجاد لوقف القتال في السودان وادخال
المساعدات وبان الهدنه مهمه للشعب
السوداني وكذلك
للرعايه الاجانب
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه في السودان
اعلن كل من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع تمديد الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه وذلك
بهدف استمرار العمليات الانسانيه واجلاء
الاجانب ورغم الجهود الدوليه للتهدئه لا
تزال هناك مخاوف من التصعيد فبحسب البيت
الابيض فان الوضع قد يزداد سوءا في ايه
لحظه في السودان وفي هذا الصدد دعا
الامريكيين الراغبين بمغادره السودان
لاستغلال الفرصه خلال اليومين المقبلين
تطورات تاتي في وقت يعاني فيه السودانيون
من انعدام في الامن
والقله في الماء والغذاء وانقطاع في
الخدمات الاساسيه
اذا هدنه جديده لمده 72 ساعه اعلنها الجيش
يبدا سريانها اعتبارا من تاريخ انتهاء
الهدنه الحاليه اي اليوم الخميس واعرب
الجيش السوداني عن امله في التزام ما
وصفهم بالمتمردين في اشاره لقوات الدعم
السريع بمتطلبات سريان الهدنه اوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تمت الاستجابه
او تم استجابه لمساعد السعوديه امريكيه
لتهيئه الظروف لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف
الجنسيات فيما اعلنت قوات دعم السريع
القبول بهذه الهدنه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان دينغ داوود
في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره
في جهودها لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال
والتفاوض مضيفا انا جنوب السودان لم تحصل
على موافقه رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره
ايجاد وان حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو هاتفيا
منذ سته ايام
ولقينا من
برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
يمكن انتاج القائد جاي
وتغير في المحال وتمشي لمحل
حتى لهنا في وقت
ما كان سايل انه الناس يكونوا يتصلوا في
اي وقت
رسلنا
رسلنا له راسلنا
لبرهاند ورسلوه كمان
الرئيس الفقير نيابه الدول
نتابع مباشره الان من اندرمان مع صحفيه
السودانيه شهدي نادر شهدي اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه ما مدى الالتزام بالهدنه وتمديدها
حتى الان
مرحبا اجمالا يمكن القول بان هذه هذه
الهدنه هي افضل هي اتعاد هي الافضل من كل
عمليات وقف اطلاق النار التي تم الاتفاق
عليها في اوقات سابقه نعم استمرت
المناوشات ما بين الفينه والاخرى ولكن بقي
يمكن ان نقول بان هذه هي افضل
ما الذي يدفعك الى قول ذلك شهدي لماذا
تعتبر ان هذه الهدنه هي افضل من سابقاتها
الاربع
نعم قاب بشكل ملحوظ
الاسلحه الثقيله الذي كان متواصلا في هذه
الاسماء وانا اتحدث معك كان حتى قبل حتى
منتصف نهارا اليوم تحليق متقطع
سلاح الجو ولكن في هذه الاثناء تعيش مدينه
ام درمان على وجه التحديد بدون نسبي الا
في بعض المناطق هذا الامر ليس اليوم وانما
بالامس واول من امس هذا الامر ممكن
المواطنين من الخروج كما اسلفت اليوم الى
الاسواق الطرفيه محاولتهم الحصول على
الحاجيات
الاساسيه
مخاوف حقيقيه بدات تبرز اضافه الى
الاقتتال وام مناطق العملي
اريد ان اتاكد منك لو سمحت يعني هذا
الهدوء الان وثبات الهدنه وصلاببتها فقط
في ام درمان ام ايضا في الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري
لا هو فقط يمكن ان نقول انه في اجزاء
واسعه من مدينه درمان باستثناء منطقتين او
او ثلاثه هي ظلت منذ اندلاع هذه الله هذه
الاحداث هي محل اشتباكات بشكل متواصل او
او متقطع ولكن احياء مثلا احياء الثورات
وقطاع عريض منها احياء منطقه ومبده تنعم
بهدوء هو هو هدوء نسبي هدوء هدوء كذلك
لعله يعني يكون مبشرا بان تكون هذه الهدنه
يعني صلبه ومتماسكه وان يتوقف يبقى متوقفا
كما ذكرت يعني دوي المدافع واطلاق الرصاص
والاشتباكات انسانيا شاهد ذكرت بان الناس
في ام درمان بداوا اليوم قليلا يعني
يخرجون لقضاء حاجياتهم حدثنا اكثر عن
الوضع الحياتي هناك عندك في اندرمان في ظل
تمديد الهدنه
نعم بدات حركه بسيطه في ميل الاسواق
الطرفيه داخل مدينه ام درمان كما تعلم ان
محطات الوقود قالبيتها وما يزال مغلق من
يعمل يشهد ازدحام بشكل كبير هذا ربما عاقه
حركه
الناس هذا في جانب في في جانب اخر كما
تعلم بان سوق درمان هو احد اكبر الاسواق
في السودان يوجد به تقريبا كل شيء محلات
اجمال
التي تبيح كل شيء للمواطنين السودانيين
اليوم بدا بحركه طفيفه ولكن كما قلت ان
عصابات النهضه المسلح بروزها اليوم كانت
هناك محاوله لي الهجوم على على السوق ولكن
تم اخمادها من المجموعات اهليه تم ودها
ولكن من المتوقع ان يتكرر هذا هذا الامر
مثلما حدث في مدينه الخرطوم بحري حينما
شاهدنا عمليات النهضه التي تعرضت لها عدد
من مصانع مخازن
المنطقه الصناعيه في ظل انشغال القوات
النظاميه بالعمليات العسكريه لحد لحد
اللحظه ايضا اليوم
بعض المستشفيات الطرفيه بدات في العوده
شيئا فشيئا نعم هي تعمل كانت خلال الفتره
السابقه وما تزال باطباء بعضهم تسد النقص
النقص الكوادر الموجود فيها اطباء متطوعين
وليسوا اهم لا هم المعينين ولكن هناك
مساعد تجزل على المستوى الاهلي على مستوى
على مستوى السكان فيما بينهم صد النفس
واستئناف تقديم الخدمات شكرا جزيلا لك
شهدي نادر مباشره من ام درمان
ومشاهدينا نرصد اخر التطورات الميدانيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه على الخارطه
التفاعليه مع زميله ليال الاختيار
لليوم الثالث عشر مشاهدينا تتواصل
العمليات العسكريه في السودان في عده
مناطق من العاصمه الخرطوم التي شهدت
اشتباكات بين كل من الجيش والدعم السريع
واسفرت عن دمار هائل كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
بخارطه المعارك في هذا المثلث الذي يشكل
ما يعرف بمثلث الخرطوم الكبرى في العاصمه
نتحدث هنا عن معارك دائره في منطقتين
نتحدث عن منطقه بحري وام دربان حيث نفذ
الجيش السوداني طلعات جويه وغارات على
مواقع للدعم السريع في كل من بحري
واندرمان مقاتلات الجيش استهدفت قوات
الدعم السريع هنا وتحديدا ايضا داخل
الخرطوم داخل العاصمه ولكن في محيط
القياده العامه والتي تعتبر نقطه
استراتيجيه يحاول الطرفان السيطره عليها
ايضا بمحيط القصر الجمهوري حيث تدور
اشتباكات بين الطرفين طبعا هنا
الدعم السريع رد بالمضادات
المضادات الارضيه على هذه الطلعات الجويه
وعلى هذا القصف من قبل الجيش السوداني
الان الى مطار الخرطوم حيث ايضا نفذ الجيش
ومشط مشطت قواته
محيط المطار كما نشاهد هنا بمحيط هذه
النقطه مطار الخرطوم الذي من اول هذه
الاشتباكات هناك اشتباكات دائره بين
الطرفين بمحيط المطار وهناك طبعا بيانات
مضاده بين الطرفين ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى
وهي نقطه الخرطوم بحري اي شمال الخرطوم
وفي ضاحيه كفوري كما نشاهد هنا حيث جددت
المقاتلات الحربيه القصف لاهداف الدعم
السريع في هذه المنطقه منطقه كفوري الذي
يقول بانه الدعم السريع طبعا احبط هجوما
على معسكره بهذه النقطه تحديدا حيث هناك
قوات للدعم السريع وكبد الجيش السوداني
خسائر هائله بهذه النقطه على حد قول الدعم
السريع طبعا ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى والى
منطقه اخرى حيث بي ام درمان اغارت مقاتلات
للجيش على منطقه صالحه هذه المنطقه ومناطق
اخرى ايضا كان هناك غارات عليها هي مناطق
قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تتمركز قوات كثيفه
وكثيره
للدعم السريع ويسعى طبعا الجيش السوداني
الى القضاء على هذه القوات اذا كانت هذه
خارطه الاشتباكات داخل الخرطوم حيث تنحصر
الاشتباكات كما شاهدنا بمحيط القياده الع
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
تدمر الحنه كلها في حاجه تانيه
[موسيقى]
ومع تعقد الوضع في الخرطومه اصبح الحصول
على صور تظهر حجم الدمار امرا نادرا وكاله
رويترز نشرت مجموعه من الصور المتفرقه
التي تم التقاطها اليوم اثار المعارك في
الخرطوم بحري حيث تظهر المشاهد الدمار
الكبير اثر المعارك دعونا نتابع بعضا من
هذه الصور
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه تمكنت
مساء اليوم من اجلها 200 شخص من رعايه دول
الشقيقه والصديقه من السودان الى جده
اضافت الخارجيه السعوديه ان اجماليا تم
اجلاؤهم من السودان منذ بدء العمليات وصل
الى نحو
1744 شخصا منهم وتسعه عشر سعوديا اما
الباقون فهم من 76 جنسيه واكدت السعوديه
ان الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم اليوم هم من
امريكا مصر البحرين الصومال لبنان
افغانستان فلسطين غامبيانا نيجيريا
باكستان كندا وتايلاند
على ظهره سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض
العربيات تواكب وصول رعايه القادمين من
السودان هذه السفينه التي تحمل على متنها
اكثر من 200 شخص وصلت لي التوع الى قائده
الملك فيصل البحريه وهي وقفت بالفعل بشكل
تام وها هي هذه اللحظات الان في انتظار
النزول الرعايه لكن هناك بروتوكول بحري
معروف لدى القوات اي او اي قوه بحريه هي
بصعود قائد الاسطول ويحيي الطاقم الملاحي
للسفينه ويحييهم ايضا لوصوله او سلامه
وصولهم على الانجاز الذي حققه اذا ايضا
ننقل الصوره من الجهه الاخرى وهي سوره
وصول الرعايه الذين وصلوا من جنسيات
مختلفه اسيويه وكذلك افريقيه وايضا بعض
الجنسيات الاوروبيه التي وصلت
على هذه اللحظات وهم قادمين بومبورت سودان
وهي سفينه قد غادرت ليله امس ووصلت في هذه
اللحظات
الى ذلك اعلنت مصر ان الجهود المبذوله
لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الاراضي
السودانيه اسفرت عن النجاح في تسهيل عبور
اكثر من 16 الف شخص من غير المصريين الى
داخل الاراضي المصريه حتى اليوم اغلبهم من
السودانيين الذين بلغ عددهم اربعه عشر الف
مواطن فروا من المناطق التي تشهد مواجهات
واعمال عنف بالاضافه الى اكثر من 2000
اجنبي من خمسين دوله وست منظمات دوليه
اجرت العربيه مقابلات حول الجاليه
العراقيه التي عادت من السودان من داخل
مطار بغداد الدولي نتابع اللي رجعنا هسه
احنا تقريبا 240 واحد لكن طبعا عندنا هناك
موجودين موجودين ظلوا عالقين والله ظلوا
عالقين
بالسودان للمسافات بعيده يعني اللي ساكن
بسناره صعب يوصل للخرطوم واللي ساكن
القضارف صعب يوصل يعني حركه التنقل في
اثناء المعارك تصير صعبه جدا صعبه الرحله
عامه مشيت بسلاسه بس هي طبعا المسافات
طويله من الخرطوم الى بورت السودان فوق 12
ساعه بالحافله
اكو يعني مثلا اماكن مشحونه ضرب ومضروب بس
احنا كنا قاعدين انا بالخرطوم بالماكينه
مكان اسمه معموره اركويت بتسمع ضرب وقصف
بس مو قريبه من يمك وصارت ظروف الحرب طبعا
وعشنا ايام صعبه والسوداني برضو عشر ايام
صعبه بس لما شفنا انه بالتلفزيون الاجلاء
لكل المواطنين الاجانب اللي قاعدين يعني
انبسطنا وقلنا ان شاء الله يعني احنا يعني
هم نطلع والحمد لله يعني سهلت امورنا
وصلنا بالسلامه
معنا من الخرطومه طاهر ساتي رئيس تحرير
صحيفه اليوم التالي استاذ طاهر اهلا بك
معنا هل الجيش والدعم السريع ملتزمان حتى
الان بتمديد الهدنه بينهما
حتى الان لم نسمع
في المحيط الذي اسكن فيه على الاقل في
المحيط الذي اسكن فيه وهو الخرطوم بحري
حتى الان لم اسمع اي صوت
كما كنا نسمع في السابق
ولكن حتى الان لا لا لم نسمع صوته ولكن لا
ادري انت ثاني ضيف معي في هذه الساعه
استاذ طاهر تؤكد على ان هناك هدوءا بعد
الاعلان عن تمديد الهدنه قبل قليل كان
معنا ضيفنا من ام درمان انت الان من
الخرطوم بحري تؤكد كذلك ان هناك هدوءا على
ما يبدو والتزام بهذه الهدنه اي اخبار
رشحت عن اذا كان قريبا سيكون هناك لقاء
بين ممثلين عن الجيش والدعم السريع وفق
مبادره الايجاده على الاقل
[موسيقى]
72 ساعه اخرى يعني الا يمهد الطريق من
وجهه نظرك الا تعتقد انه يعني بادره بادره
مبشره ربما بان الطرفين سيوفدان ممثلين
عنهما الى جبى في
[موسيقى]
ولكن ولكن هي كانت تطالب كثيرا وطالبه
بالهدنه ولكن الان
اطلاق النار من قبل ما هو عدم حركتهم بل
هي للهدنه
كالعادهم عن الفتره الاخيره عن عن الهجوم
ما عدا
بعض الجيوب التي هنا وهناك ولكن لا يوجد
نشاط فاعل لهذه المليكه الاخيره ولكن 24
ساعه القادمه ستحدث ان كانت هي استجابه
للهدنه ام هي اصلا بطبيعها علمته لم تعد
قادرا على القتال نعم ولكن الاستاذ طاهر
يعني تلمسون ان هناك فرقا بين الهدى
السابقه التي يعني كانت هشه الى حد بعيد
مع هذه الهدنه الجديده
صحيح حتى الان لو باعتبار ان الهدنه لو
اعتبرنا بدات مساء اليوم هذه الساعات
ليست تقريبا ده خاصه ان العمليات العسكريه
دائما ما تكون في اول المساء واول الصباح
لو لو التزمت الاطراف صباح الغد بعدم خلق
الهدنه يكون هذا التزاما من الطرفين ولذلك
الحكم على
الالتزام الاطراف السابق لاواني طيب استاذ
طاهر يعني نحن نكاد
يكاد يمضي الاسبوع الثاني من هذه المواجهه
العسكريه
حياتيا كيف يتدبر السودانيون الذين بقيوا
في منازلهم ولم ينزحوا عنها كيف يتدبرون
امورهم في هذه المرحله الان في مع نهايه
تقريبا الاسبوع الثاني
هناك هناك في بعض المناطق وخاصه المناطق
التي تحيط القياده العامه وحي المطار وهي
الاحياء الكويت المعموره بري
وحي المطار والامارات هذه الاحياء في محيط
في محيط القتال ولكن اجزاء واسعه محليات
كامله في ولايه الخرطوم لم تعد تتاثر بما
يحدث بل عدد الحياه والاسواق المركزيه في
شاهد في الخرطوم ثلاثه اسواق مركزيه الان
عادت الى اليها النشاط وكذلك الخطوط
المواصلات الداخليه في مساحتها واسعه اما
الاقاليم فهي غير متاثره بهذه الحرب فمنذ
اليوم منذ اليوم الرابع او الخامس عاده
الهدوء الى اقاليم السودان ما عدا الجنيه
مدينتي الجنينه
الى النقطه التاليه التي ساتحدث عنها في
التقرير الموالي وسطاهر ارجو ان تبقى معنا
سنتابع الوضع هناك في دارفور ونعود للنقاش
اليك
مشاهدينا ايضا تجدد القتال في اقليم
دارفور المضطرب غرب السودان ويبدو انها
تتخذ ابعادا قبليه هناك معارك عنيفه
واشتباكات وصفات الامم المتحده بالدميه
شهدتها مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب
دارفور بين عناصر الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع مستخدمين مختلف انواع الاسلحه
القتال العنيف تحول الى نزاع بين قبيله
المثاليه الافريقيه والقبائل العربيه
واستخدمت فيه الاسلحه الثقيله عشرات
القتلى من المدنيين سقطوا ومئات الجرحى
اصيبوا ولم يتم اسعافهم بسبب صعوبه
الاوضاع الامنيه وانتشار المسلحين
القبليين في اجزاء واسعه من مدينه الجنينه
عدا عن تزايد اعمال النهب للمؤسسات
الحكوميه والمقر والمنظمات الامميه وسوق
الجنينه وحرق عدد كبير من المنازل وفق
مسؤولين في حكومه غرب دارفور الى جانب
توزيع الاسلحه بين المجتمعات المحليه ما
يزيد من خطر الفوضى والعنف هذه التطورات
دفعت بعدد من سكان الجنينه الى الفرار
باتجاه الحدود السودانيه تشاديه رغم اغلاق
الحكومه للحدود هناك بين البلدين ومنذ
عقدين مشاهدينا يعيش اقليم دارفور الطلبات
الامنيه كبيره تخللتها انتهاكات واسعه
تسببت بمقتل قرابه ثلاثه الاف شخص ونزوح
مليونين ونصف المليون شخص
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا عاجل اذا الان القوى المدنيه موقعه
على الاتفاق الايطاليه الذي كان من
المفترض ان يتم التوقيع على الاتفاق نهائي
فيه يعني في نهايه ابريل الجاري قبل ان
تحدث هذه المواجهات هذه القوى المدنيه
ترحب بتمديد الهدنه في السودان اذا
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع طبعا بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه اعود
الى ضيفي الاستاذ طاهر الساتي من الخرطوم
بحري استاذ طاهر ما مدى خطوره هذه
المواجهات القبليه خصوصا في غرب دارفور
وعلاقتها بما يحدث من مواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في الخرطوم
المواجهات القبليه في دارفور بما يحدث
في تقدير ان هذه المواجهه هذه الحرب في
الاشتباكات في دار الاشتباكات القبليه في
دار خور بعمر دارفور حتى قبل حتى اثناء
هذه ليست الاولى من قبل اسابيع كانت هنالك
اشتباك
وقبلها في الجنينه زادها وهذه هي الثالثه
ولكن ربما
الانشغال القوات المسلحه بالدعم بقتال
الدعم السريع في مدهشه
هذه المواجهات في الخرطوم يعني
ادت الى نوع من انواع الانفلات كذلك وخروج
الضغائن او ال ال الخلافات القديمه في غرب
دارفور
نعم
انشغال القوات المسلحه والامنيه الاخرى
الدعم السريع ربما ادى الى خلل امني
استغلتها هذه القبائل في الاشتباك ولكن
ولكن
لا هذه الحرب
تستهدف بشكل مباشر
على القوات المسلحه وكانت في
القوات المسلحه وهي لا تستهدف مجموعه
اسميه ولا مجموعه عرقيه بل هي تستهدف حركه
متمرده بشكل مباشر
شكرا جزيلا لك طاهر سياتي رئيس تحرير
صحيفه اليوم التالي كنت معنا مباشره من
الخرطوم
كليفري ان الوضع في السودان قد يتفاقم في
الايام المقبله كما اكد على ان بلاده
ستواصل الدعم للرعايه البريطانيه
وقف اطلاق النار ليس مقدمه بالضروره
للسلام والوضع في السودان من الممكن ان
يتفاقم في الايام المقبله ونحن سنواصل
الدعم للرعايه البريطانيين لذلك نحن
موجودون في بورتسودان ولدينا مسؤولون
دبلوماسيون في مصر واثيوبيا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الازمه في السودان موجه هجره جديده صحيفه
التلغراف البريطانيه تتوقع نزوح اعداد
مهوله من السكان وبالتالي زياده في عدد
المهاجرين غير النظاميين
فبريطانيا وحدها قد تشهد لجوء اعداد كبيره
من السودانيين الامم المتحده تقول ان عددا
كبيرا من اللاجئين السودانيين فروا الى
بلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الازمه مع توقعات
بنزوح مئه الف سوداني الى تشاد ومئه
وسبعين الفا الى جنوب السودان بالاضافه
الى مصر وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
بدورها تناشد الامم المتحده جميع الدول
بجوار السودان ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الذين يبحثون عن الاماني والحمايه
[موسيقى]
طلبه نيجيريون في السودان قوات الدعم
السريع باستخدام الطلبه كدروع بشريه ونقلت
وكاله رويترز عن الطلاب النيجيريين قولهم
ان الدعم السريع يتخذ منهم دروعا بشريه في
جامعه افريقيا الدوليه بالخرطوم ولم يتسنى
للعربيه التاكد من صحه هذه الانباء كما
عبر الطلبه عن احباطهم من بطء وتيره
عمليات الاجلاء مشيرين الى ان عمليات
اجلاء نيجيريين بدات مساء امس حيث نقلت
المجموعه الاولى الى مصر ويقدر عدد
المقيمين النيجيريين في السودان بخمسه
الاف وخمسمئه نيجيري معظمهم من الطلاب
ولاول مره تكشف روسيا رسميا عن دور قوات
فاجنر في السودان بعد ان اعلن وزير
الخارجيه لوسيس ان للسودان الحق في
الاستفاده من خدمه فاغنر كيف عززت روسيا
حضورها في السودان نتابع في التالي
وموسكو تكشف رسميا ولاول مره عن دور
مجموعه فاغنر هناك وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ومن المقر الاممي في نيويورك كشف ان
للسودان الحق في الاستفاده من خدمات بادنر
فضلا عن كلامي رئيس فارنير اكد استعداد
مجموعته للتدخل في حال طلب الشعب السوداني
ذلك
الشعب السوداني فسارسل بالتاكيد مهمه حفظ
سلام الى السودان من قبل شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه ولو كانت فاجنر هناك
اعتقد ان الحرب لم تكن لتبدا في السودان
فاجنر لا تبدا الحروب انما تنهيها دائما
لكن كيف تطورت العلاقات السودانيه الروسيه
وصولا الى تعزيز دور فاغنر موسكو اسست
لوجودها في السودان منذ عهد البشير من
خلال تحسين شروط عمل شركات الطاقه الروسيه
واخرى تنشط في مجال التنقيب عن الذهب
والثروات الاخرى ايضا ابرز ما عزز الوجود
الروسي في السودان هو سلاح الذي اصبحت
بسببه المصدر الرئيسي للجيش السوداني
فتحولت الخرطوم الى ثاني شريك عسكري
لروسيا في القاره الافريقيه بعد الجزائر
بعد تلك الخطوات وتحديدا عام 2017
وقع السودان اتفاقا مع روسيا لانشاء قاعده
عسكريه على البحر الاحمر تستضيف سفنا
روسيه بما في ذلك سفن تعمل بالوقود النووي
على ان يتمركز فيها 300 جندي اتفاق
خلق الغرب بدوره في تعزيز الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه في افريقيا وعلى سواحل البحر
الاحمر
ورغم وقف العمل بالاتفاقيه بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير الى ان مصالح موسكو في السودان
دفعتها الى الابقاء على علاقه وثيقه مع
اللاعبين الاساسيين خلال السنوات الماضيه
لكن تميزت مع احمدتي خصوصا على خلفيه
تزايد التقارير حول امداد قواته بالسلاح
والمساعده العسكريه الروسيه من خلال قوات
فاجنر محاسن حضاره العربيه
معنى من لندن عمار حموده القيادي في حزب
التجمع الاتحاديه والناطق الرسمي للقوى
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي بالخارج
مرحبا بكم معنا استاذ عمار في العربيه ما
الذي تفعله فاجنر في السودان
مرحب بك
و
غيرها كل ذلك هو مخلفات حقبه سابقه ووضع
شاذ
ومحاولات اللعب على كاف على على كل الحبال
وبالنهايه صناعه جيوش موازيه صناعه
ماليشيا موازيه
الشيء الذي عقد من مهام الانتقال ومهام
معالجه هذه الامور بصوره
جذريه بصوره تحل مشاكلها والى الابد كل ما
نراه الان هو
بعض لمرض قديم نحن نحاول من ناحيه سياسيه
معالجته حتى في مظاهره العسكريه ولذلك
هي عرض عرض لمرض كبير وهو عدم التفات
المؤسسات العسكريه لدورها الاساسي وعملها
بالسياسه او ما كان سابقا من انها تكون
مطيه لجهات سياسيه تتلاعب بامر المواطن
تتلاعب بالامن القومي تتلاعب على كل
الحبال السياسيه في المنطقه
كقوه مدنيه
ما موقفكم من الاستعانه الان بقوات فاغنر
كما قال
وزير الخارجيه الروسي بانه بالامكان
الاستعانه بالقوات قوات فاجنر الموجوده
هناك
هذه مساله يعني غير وارده في حسابات الدول
المحترمه في حسابات اي دوله تحترم شعبها
وتحترم نفسها وتعطي اولويه لان تتولى زمام
امرها من ناحيه امنيه من الصعوب بمكان
التفكير بالاستعانه باطراف خارجيه سواء
كانت عسكريه او غيرها خصوصا اذا كانت
عسكريه هذا امر يعني بالغ
الحساسيه ولذلك من يتحدثون بمثل هذه
الطريقه في السودان او الذين فعلوا ذلك
خانتهم الحساسيه
السياسيه ولا الامنيه والعسكريه في انه
يعرف
انتقل الى نقطه اخرى نتابع الان هذا
العاجل الدعم السريع يؤكد التزامه بالهدنه
لتسهيل اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه كيف تنظرون استاذ عمار الى
الى موضوع الالتزام بالهدنه وتمديدها وهل
يعني هذا يعني انه بعد اجلاء الرعايه
والبعث الدبلوماسيه يعني ستعود رحاء الحرب
او يعود الاقتتال على اشده مره اخرى
كنت اتمنى انه دعم السريع او الجيش
السوداني حينما يتحدث عن هدنه يتحدث عن
المواطنين السودانيين قبل ما نتحدث عن
رعايه الدول الاخرى نعم الحرب لا تعرف
يعني اجنبي او وطني ولكن درجه جهات
الوطنيه ان تذكر ما يليها بدايه مواطنيها
ثم بعد ذلك تحدث عن مواطني دول اخرى هذه
نقطه ثانويه النقطه الجوهريه ان هذه
الهدنه اذا لم تكن حقيقيه فانها تستعمل
بصوره سيئه لاعاده ملا البنادق كما ذكرنا
والاستعداد من جديد
او لوضع شروط جديده
لكنها تعطي انطباعا سيئا للذين ينمون ان
يستغلوا الهدنه في غطاء حوائج معيشيه
حياتيه بسيطه في انه
يتوهمون ان هناك امان ثم يقدر بهم احد
الاطراف او تاتيهم قذيفه من هنا او هناك
الهدنه يجب ان تتمدد الى وقف شامل لاطلاق
لان هذا المسار هو المسار الذي يفصلنا الى
وجود حل سياسي
تقف البنادق اولا ايجاد مشتركات ومسهلين
وطاوله مفاوضات ثم الوصول الى حل سياسي
لان المشكله هذا مشكل سياسي وان كان تمظهر
عدم في فلتان عسكري او من الباب العسكري
الان اللغه لغه عسكريه والجو جو عسكري نحن
علينا ان نقيم الجبهه المدنيه الكبيره لكي
تواجه شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك عمار حموده انتم
القيادي في حزب التجمع الاتحادي والناطق
الرسمي لقوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي بالخارج كنت معنا من لندن
اذا مشاهدينا وعوده الى ملف اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب اذا من السودان باتجاه جده نذهب
الى هناك الان حيث وصل الطائره اجلاء
هنديه الان من السودان الى قاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه هنصفيه معنا من هناك هاني
المزيد عن وصول هذه الطائره الجديده
نعم اهلا صهيب اذا طائره اجراء جديده
عسكريه هنديه تصل هذه اللحظات الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه
على متنها اكثر من
120 شخص
هذه اللحظات الاولى الان التي يتم فيها
نزول الرعايه وهم جميعهم من الجنسيه
الهنديه
باستثناء ثلاثه اشخاص هم من الجنسيه
السودانيه يعملون في القنصليه الفرنسيه
طبعا الرعايه جميعهم هم بحاله صحيه جيده
وايضا تم دخول الطاقم الطبي قبل قليل الى
داخل الطائره ونشاهد يعني الفرحه على وجوه
يعني هؤلاء الواصلين الى جده الان من
السودان
صحيح نعم هي فرحه سعاده ومع فرحه من
تاثيرات ايضا ومشاهد قد شاهدوها في في
هناك في السودان طبعا هناك بعض
المجندات السعوديات في القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه يقوم بترحيبهم واعطائهم
ايضا بعض الورود وايضا بعض الحلوى طبعا في
مقدمه استقبال
الرعايه هو وزير الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه
الهنديه وبجانبه قائد قطاع او قائد قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه اللواء عبد الله
الزهراني وكذلك السفيره الفرنسيه هنا
ونشاهد هذه اللحظات اوكي
فرحتها هذه السيده وهي سيده
من السودان تعبر عن فرحتها بوصولها وهي
التي كنا نتحدث عنها وهي تعمل في السفر
كانت الرحله ممتازه ممتازه الحمد لله انك
تعملين في السفراء الفرنسيه في الخرطوم
طيب كيف يتم عمليه الاجلاء ووصولك هناك
بكل سهوله السفاره الفرنسيه السفير
الفرنسيه نسقت مع
السفيره الهندي وتم اجرائها عبر
امورك صحتك عافيتك ما هو حال الخرطوم
صعب شويه دعواتكم للخرطوم شكرا شكرا لك
اذا هي تتحدث عن سلامتها وعن ايضا كيف تم
تسهيل مهامها وايضا مهام خروجها والوصول
على
نذكر هاني بالحدث الذي نتبعه اذا الان على
الهواء مباشره وصول طائره هنديه من
السودان وصولها الى جده بالتحديد الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه حيث تسهل
السعوديه وتساعد في اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
هذه واحده من عديد الرحلات البحريه
والجويه كذلك التي نسقت فيها السعوديه
واستقبلت فيها الرعايه الاجانب واخراجهم
من السودان واستضافتهم في السعوديه ومن ثم
عودتهم الى بلادهم هاني كما تفضلت يعني
هذه الطائره فيها عدد كبير من الجاليه
الهنديه التي كانت موجوده في السودان ولكن
فيها ايضا بعض السودانيين
هي طائره عسكريه هنديه في هذه الطائره
تحمل 123 شخص 23 وثلاثه اشخاص هم من
الجنسيه السودانيه الذين كانوا يعملون كما
ذكرت في القنصليه الفرنسيه وكانت السفيره
الفرنسيه في استقبالهم وايضا المئه وعشرين
المتبقون هم من رعايه الهند طبعا اليوم
بالنسبه لمدينه جده واختيار ايضا كمنطقه
او مدينه
كي تسهل عمليه او تسهل عمليه وصول الرعايه
سواء من الجاليه الهنديه او كذلك الجنسيات
الاخرى يعني كنا ايضا العربيه كانت تواكب
خلال الايام الماضيه
عمليه الاجلاء سواء عبر السفن البحريه او
كذلك عبر الاسطول الجوي او الجسر الجوي
وايضا عبر الثلاثه مواقع وهي قاعده الملك
عند الله الجويه التي نتحدث فيها وكذلك
ميناء جدا اسلامي وايضا قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه هذه المواقع هي في مدينه جده هي
مجهزه وايضا موجوده من اجل استقبال كافه
الرحلات سواء كانت هذه الرحلات هي
العمليات اجلاب تابعه للقوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه او ايضا للقوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه او ايضا للفرقاطات
العسكريه من دول اخرى او للسفن التجاريه
التي تقوم باجلاء رعاياها كنا ايضا نواكب
عمليه اجلاء لبعض الرعايه من الصين وكذلك
من بعثه الامم المتحده عبر الفرقاط
الفرنسيه لورين وكذلك اليوم في صباح اليوم
كان هناك سفينتين عسكريتين صينيتين وصلتها
وتحمل على متنها اكثر من 670 شخص وكانت
هناك ايضا فرقاطه عسكريه
هنديه وقفت في منها جدا الاسلامي وتعمل
على متنها 1995 الان هو الجسر الجوي
ونشاهد عمليه استمرار السعوديه ساعدت اذا
في اجلاء الالاف من الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان سواء بحريا او جويا هل نعرف اذا
كانت يعني يعني جهود الاجلاء هذه ستستمر
عبر السعوديه والى متى هاني
عمليه نجلاء مستمره واضح جدا يا صهيب من
خلال ما عمليات الرصد التي كنا نواكبها
ونقوم بتغطيتها في بدايه عمليه الاجلاء
كانت مقتصره على سفينه ثم او سفينتين وبعد
ذلك تبعها ثلاثه سفن اليوم هناك ثمن سفن
ونتحدث عن عشرين طائره اذا هناك المزيد من
الرعايه والجاليات الموجوده في السودان
ايضا في الجانب الاخر كنا نتحدث ايضا مع
الرعايه الذين يصلون وكنا ناخذ معهم بعض
المشاهد وبعض الاحاديث والاعداد الموجوده
التي يشاهدونها المعظم قال انه يغادر
يوميا الف وياتي الف اخرون مكانهم اذا
العدد هناك بالالاف نستطيع ان نقول ذلك
ويعتقد ان عمليه الاجراء سوف تستمر لان
ايضا بعض القنصليات غادرت القصريات لبعض
البلدان غادرت واضطرت الى مغادره الى برج
سودان من اجل انهاء اجراءات رعاياها
السفير الفلسطيني مثلا تحدث ان تسعين
بالمئه من الجاليه الفلسطينيه غادره
السودان وهي تتواجد في جده السفير او
القنصل العام الاندونيسي تحدث ايضا
للعربيه ان ما وصل العدد الموجود في
السودان اكثر من الف شخص من الجاليه
الاندونيسيه ومن الجنسيه الاندونيسيه غادر
غادر منها
783 وتبقى الدفعه الاخيره سوف تاتي عبر
جسر جوي ايضا بالنسبه للجاليه النيروبيه
وايضا هناك اكثر من
2600 شخص من يوروبيه ما زالوا عالقين هناك
في السودان اضافه الجنسيات الاخرى عمليه
الجنسيات هي بالالاف بحسب شهود عيانه بحسب
ما تحدثوا لنا في هذا الامر لا ننسى ايضا
ان ايضا استمرار الجسر الجوي وكذلك الجسر
البحري وايضا العمليات الاجرام مستمره
طالما ان
المنافذ التي وفرتها السعوديه سواء
المنافذ البحريه او الجويه هي مفتوحه كافه
البلدان نعم اعود استفسر لو سمحت يعني
السعوديه تقود هذه الجهود الانسانيه يعني
منذ بدايه الازمه وبمجرد يعني كان هناك
مجال لاخراج العالقين في السودان
لا اعلم اذا كان هناك الان تصريح
[موسيقى]
اذا نشاهد الشكر اذا الطاقم السعودي لطاقم
الطائره الهنديه تفضل لهاني
اليوم
او كذلك
رعايه البلدان طبعا مثل ما
تكلمت انت الان ومثل ما شفت اليوم او كانت
العمليات مستمره يعني منذ يوم الاثنين
يوجد هناك طائرات مدنيه وبعض الدول تستاجر
طائرات المدنيه او تستخدم طائرات مدنيه
ودول اخرى استخدمت الطائرات القوات الجويه
لكل دوله مثل الهند تستخدم هذه الطائره
طبعا تابع القوات الجويه الهنديه
عندنا في القاعده هنا الحمد لله وفرنا لهم
جميع الامكانيات من ناحيه الباركينج
الخدمات المطلوبه للاطقم الجويه اللي
للطائرات طبعا حنا حريصين على ان الاطقم
الجويه يعني يجدون يعني الوقت الكافي
للراحه المكان المناسب ليتمكنوا من تخطيط
الى المهام القادمه ايضا
ليستطيعوا اداء المهام لانهم يحتاجون
صراحه الى وقت راحه
توفير السكن توفير امور كثيره لهم
بالاضافه الى التنسيق مع الشركات التي
تقوم بدعم ومسانده الطائرات من ناحيه
التزود بالوقود
والكيترنج او التمويل اللي عاشها وامور
اخرى كثيره
فالحمد لله يعني بجهود جميع الزملاء
وتعاون الاصدقاء كذلك واعطكم الطائرات
القادمه
لاجلاء الرعايه الحمد لله تمكنا من النجاح
تمكنا من الى الان وان شاء الله نستمر في
النجاح حتى نهايه العمليات سعاده اللواء
الركن عبد الله الزهراني قائد قائده الملك
عبد الله الجويه في القطاع الغربي في
مدينه
جده بالنسبه للمعلومات التي لديكم مطر
بورتو السودان اليوم يعني بورتسودان كنا
نشاهد طائرتين عسكريتين سعوديتين كانت
تنقل بعض الرعايه هل هو مهيا كمطار عسكري
امطار مدني ايضا هو في الحقيقه المعلومه
اللي عندنا انه مطار مدني
ويعني ليس بحجم المطارات الموجوده لدينا
ولكن الحمد لله كان كافي لاستقبال
الطائرات طبعا احنا
نتكلم مع الاطقم الجويه بعد نزولهم
ونسالهم عن حاله المطار وعن التهديد اذا
كان هناك تهديد او هل في امكانيه لمواصله
العمليات
والحمد لله حتى الان الوضع امن في بورت
سودان حسب التقارير اللي حصلنا عليها من
اطقم الجويه ما بعد المهام الامور جيده
جدا وان شاء الله بامكاننا نحن والدول
الاخرى من الاصدقاء والاشقاء مواصله
عمليات الاجلاء باذن الله تعالى
البحث باذن الله تعالى حتى انتهاء عمليه
اجلاد الرعايه شكرا لك شكرا لك العفو شكرا
لكم جميعا على وجودكم معنا ومشاركتنا شكرا
لك اذا كان حديث اللواء ركن عبد الله
الزهراني وهو قائد قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه
ان هناك نعم تفضل عذرا على المقاطعه شكرا
لك شكرا سياده اللواء لانه اجاب على
السؤال الذي كنت اريد ان اطرحه عليك هاني
عن مسار التكفل بالواصلين الى جده بعد
قدومهم من السودان شكرا جزيلا لك ولضيفك
الكريم مباشره من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في جده
[موسيقى]
والان الى موجزين لابرز الاخبار الدوليه
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل شاب
فلسطينيين بالرصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه واقل الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الشاب حاول تنفيذ عمليه دهس وبعدها حاول
طعن اشخاص بسكين قرب مستوطنه اريال هذا
واوضحت وسائل الاعلام الفلسطينيه ان الشاب
يدعى احمد يعقوب طه ويبلغ من العمر 39
عاما
من اثار رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
امام مقر المحكمه العليا بمدينه القدس
تاييدا لخطه التعديلات القضائيه المثيره
للجدل يذكر ان التعديلات احدثت انقساما في
الشارع الاسرائيلي بين مؤيد ومعارض حيث
ستحد التعديلات القضائيه من سلطه المحكمه
العليا وتعطي السياسيين صلاحيات اكبر في
اختيار القضاه
دعا رئيس الوزراء الارماني الارميني عفوا
روسيا الوسيط في النزاع مع اذربيجان دعاه
الى الحفاظ على سيطرتها على طريق حيوي في
منطقه ناجورني كارباخ المتنازع عليها ياتي
هذا بعدما وضعت باكو نقطه تفتيش على مدخل
المرر واتهمت ارمينيا باكو بقطع هذا
الطريق الحيوي منذ حوالي سته اشهر
قال رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
خلال خطابنا القهوه امام الكونغرس
الامريكي ان بلاده سترد بشكل حازم على
استفزازات كوريا الشماليه
يشكل برنامج كوريا الشماليه النووي
والاستفزازات الصاروخيه تهديدا خطيرا
للسلام في شبه الجزيره الكوريه وخارجها
لردع هذا السلوك المتهور يجب ان يقف الحلف
متحدا سترد حكومه بحزم على الاستفزازات
لكن في الوقت نفسه سنبقي الباب مفتوحا
للحوار ونزع السلاح النووي لكوريا
الشماليه
اذا كانت هذه مجموعه من اخبار العالم نعود
الان الى استكمال تغطيه الاحداث في
السودان ساعه اخرى اذا بعد قليل مع طاهر
بركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات